عندما ننزعج نشعر بالحراره وعندما نغضب
الدم يغلي العلماء الان كشفوا عن التفاعل
المعقد بين الحراره الشديده ونتائج الصحه
العقليه السيئه مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره
ترتفع معادلات الانتحار والجريمه والعنف
فوفقا لدراسه اجرت بجامعه عام 2018 فان
الزياده في متوسط درجات الحراره بمقدار
درجه مئويه واحده في الولايات المتحده
والمكسيك ترتبط بزياده قدرها 1% في حالات
الانتحار اليات العلاقه بين الحراره
ووظائف المخ غير مفهومه جيدا ويمكن ارجاع
الكثير منها الى النوم الذي يصبح بعيد
المنال في موجه حار دون تكييف ومع مرور
الوقت يمكن ان تؤدي الاثار التراكميه لقله
النوم الى فقدان الذاكره وقله التركيز
وزياده التهيج تؤثر الحراره ايضا على
الناقل العصبي السيرتونين احد اهم منظمات
الحاله المزاجيه لدينا والذي يرتبط
ارتباطا وثيقا بمراقبه العدوانيه فهل
علينا ان نفكر في تغير المناخ باعتباره
ازمه صحه نفسيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات